thank you for joining us for the press
conference following the 15 summit
between nu and India we will issue at
the end of the press conference the
joint statement and a new joint agenda
for cooperation the roadmap 2025 and the
joint declaration on resource efficiency
but first I give the floor to the
President of the European Council thank
you good afternoon everyone it was a
pleasure to speak with Prime Minister
Modi today India is an indispensable
partner our meeting clearly shows
importance that both the EU and India
attach to our relationship as the
world's two largest democracies we share
common values freedom will flow and
respect for human rights
we have convergent interests and today
we focused on three important topics
first 12:19 and rebuilding our economic
prosperity
suddenly our EU India bilateral
relationship and third regional and
security issues as power dynamics shift
across the globe the EU wants to play a
stronger role in the region and as a
double actor today's substantive
dialogue with India will reinforce these
strategic roles the U and India are
banding together to fight over 19 and I
welcome India's role in tackling the
virus both at the regional and global
level and their contribution to the
research and manufacturing of vaccine
which should be available to all we will
cooperate to strengthen our health
systems and ensure the w-h-o is
effective we agree that the economic and
social recovery must be more sustainable
more resilient and leave nobody behind
the global trading system open will play
an important role efforts in the g20 and
UN will also be vital
we welcome India's support for that we
live as well to this meeting marked the
15th summit between India and the
European Union the EU is India's largest
trade and investment partner but India
represents only about two percent of EU
External Trade this is clearly an area
that offers impressive potential for
significant future growth we agreed to
enhance conditions for traders and
investors we called for ambitious
climate and environmental action the EU
is a partner of India's sustainable
modernization including through
investments by the European Investment
Bank over 4 billion euros we will also
work together to deploy digital
technologies based on our shared values
and global standards we have just signed
the Eurasian India agreement that boost
cooperation on research and development
for peaceful nuclear energy we welcome
in this proposal to build a connectivity
partnership that's open sustainable and
rules-based the you and India will
further develop security and defence
consultations and military contact we
will step up our cooperation to fight
terrorism and cyber threats Europol and
its Indian counterpart will join forces
to tackle organized crime we'll also
work to enforce maritime security
especially in the Indian Ocean where 40%
of our trade passes and we'll continue
our dialogue on human rights and I will
serve on the on the UN Security Council
in 2021 2022 and assume the presidency
of
20 in 2022 the EU looked forward to
working with India in these
organizations and others to strengthen
multilateralism and the rules-based
international order the U and India are
more than economic partners we are
political partners committed to peaceful
resolution of conflicts security and
rule of law to this meeting clearly
showed that both the EU and India wants
a stronger strategic relationship for
the future the concrete commitments we
made today reflect this strand and clear
ambition India can count on the European
Union and we count on India to be a key
partner I thank you madam president yes
thank you indeed today our main message
was has been that the European Union
stands by India as friends and partners
and I want to focus on the other topics
indeed of course our joint focus
continues to be on slowing the spread of
the virus worldwide and saving lives but
we've also discussed the necessary steps
to modernize the global economy and
there of course climate action and the
green transition must be at the heart of
our economic recovery both in the
European Union and in India as well you
know that the European Union has
committed to its European Green Deal
however we are completely aware of the
fact that at the global level we will
not make a difference unless we work
with partners like India and therefore
we explained our objective to reach
climate neutrality by 2050 to modernize
our industries to rethink our energy mix
India's very strong on solar energy for
example to engage in a circular economy
and to ensure that the transition is
just and fair for all our citizens we
strengthened the fact that our global
economic recovery provide
with a huge opportunity to invest now in
modern in clean and in healthy economies
allowing us to reach long-term climate
goals and we raised with Prime Minister
Modi of course the fact that this means
making tough choices such as phasing out
of coal but it is a unique opportunity
now to step forward so very good is that
we agreed that we will be able to
convene a specific climate change
dialogue this is a nice deliverable of
this summit to discuss in this climate
change dialogue how to strengthen our
cooperation in the areas of solar power
in the area of offshore wind energy
resource efficiency and of course the
circular economy another topic was the
digital transformation India is a
natural partner for the European Union
in this respect we share a human centric
approach this means using secure digital
technologies to improve the quality of
life of citizens but at the same time
respecting privacy and individual
freedoms and our cooperation with India
in this area is already flourishing but
there is still a huge potential for
stronger cooperation so I confirm to
Prime Minister Modi our willingness to
share our experience in data protection
protection legislation we think that a
convergence of standards would greatly
facilitate the data flows between us
likewise we are looking forward to
engaging with India on the deployment of
trustworthy artificial intelligence
India has hundreds of thousands of
highly qualified graduates in the
digital and the computing sectors every
year and if we can bring together our
complementary resources and the
opportunities we can achieve much more
the same goes for
are developing common global standards
when it comes to secure 5g deployment or
our joint work on high performance
computers all these have been topics
we've been discussing during the summit
and a third point I want to focus on is
trade and investment of course as with
all global supply chains avoiding market
access barriers and ensuring fair and
transparent competition remains
essential we raised that topic to I have
proposed to the prime minister that we
engage in a high-level EU India digital
investment forum in which our business
leaders can discuss concrete
opportunities for cooperation and issues
of concern and today indeed has given us
an opportunity to address the untapped
potential of our trade relationship as
Charl just mentioned the European Union
and India are two of the largest
economies and markets in the world about
6,000 European companies are present in
India the European Union is India's
largest trading partner and is the
largest investor in India yet our
overall trade and investment
relationship has by no means reached its
full potential and therefore it is very
positive that today we have established
a high level trade and investment
dialogue so on the level of the minister
and the respective Commissioner here at
the European Union's level it will
address multilateral issues and it will
look to advance towards both an
investment protection and trade
agreements we want an ambitious a
vicious trade agreement we are not there
yet
but with this high-level Trade and
Investment dialogue we hope to advance
things and to promote our common
interest in moving forward towards a
free trade agreement it needs to be to
include our usual requirements in terms
of market access and
public procurement and of course
sustainable development so there is
still a way to go let me conclude by
stressing indeed that the European Union
and India are the world's largest
democracy and we must work more closely
to promote and protect our shared
interests based on effective
multilateralism based on the rule of law
and human rights and in this context we
welcomed India's recent election as a
non permanent member of the UN Security
Council and as chair of g20 in 2020 -
thank you madam president
for the Q&A session may I please ask you
to turn on your camera's switch it on
thank you and raise your blue hand if
you want to raise a question to the
presidents I have a first question from
Siddhant Siebel could you please state
your medium as well and clearly say whom
you want to address your question to
please Chinese was that discussed during
the summit we know between India and
China at the border so how much this job
means between European leaders and of
course Indian leaders yes we discussed
this topic and probably you know that a
few weeks ago we had a videoconference
assume it by videoconference with the
Chinese authorities and as you know the
relationship between the European Union
and China is complex we need to tackle
different issue different topics and
indeed we are in favor of a peaceful
solution
Prime Minister Modi had the occasion
also to inform us to inform us about the
latest developments regarding this
incident is China with China and we
support all the efforts in order to
maintain a channel of dialogue in order
to find peaceful solutions
next question is for David kureta
tragedy Callie David yes thank you very
much for the opportunity that would
characterize radical Italian radio a
political question if I may is India
more strategic for you than China thank
you the second news even envision the
world's premiere the filly lost moles in
vitamin C to Chanel oma desala the whole
primary solo Internacional communion
hope in u.s. awesome sunny City MO and
Porto the man Neha and DLR debajo de la
moneda on foxy depart Navia avocado peed
on moon if you save it land in your open
11d sunder democracy with the tradition
volodymyr hearted respect polluted water
SP poor militarily monovalent Redondo to
the domain idea and potential to develop
advantage reverses wah oh ma TF
commercial normative economic justice
wasn't resolved on climatic education
digital from thermo s own selves our
transformation preservable
appellate remedy Le Poisson concrete
news even fate poor impressive la
coopération Souter halitosis ajidasu
extra important in Casa de monte isola
plum political dimension a large nod at
important part renew de fondo fa t mo
envision a globalization envisioned
immortal spirit dust under democratic
considered IBT de france abyss or
foundatio languages behavior survey lon
es la la la function or non permanent a
possible security poor appeared DeMille
event Edwin van der Sar responsibilities
dosa riservato ordinate Rondo en voiture
aha - Lisa G de Bordeaux area in real
velocity true parents important a the
rapport she know cuando su f and avoir
un a free ala mode get a spear a
polyvinyl don't Kim Cuong come in your
hotel
indeed China and India are both
important to us but both are very
different and if you look at the topics
we have with China and with India common
interest what the fight against climate
change is concerned this is very
important
China and India are very important if we
want to be successful in the fight
against climate change with both we have
strong trade relations but on very
different fields we have reinforcing in
common interest and on others we have
issues but the difference is indeed that
we share with India that we are
democracies and therefore I can relate
to what shall Michel said concerning the
democracies and defending our values I
will take another question from an
Indian journalist Smita Sharma can you
hear us Mita
yes could you raise your volume and live
just a little bit is it clear now yes
just follow-up question because you know
there have been some intelligence
reports from other countries that have
spoken about the number of Indians or
the number of Chinese soldiers who were
killed in the Galvan clashes does the EU
have any input you may have shared on
this is your assessment that now you do
see a de-escalation happening or there
is a possible flare-up that may still
happen across the LSC between India and
China and a last question because you
spoke about the shared principles of
democracies the a citizenship Amendment
Act protests and you know the way
India has rounded up activists many of
them are still in jail for having
protested against the amendment is that
something that came up in your thoughts
today thank you maybe two to answer so
the first one I don't venture in this
direction
we had the occasion like I said with the
prime minister to have some information
about this incident and I would like to
repeat that for the European Union is
important to encourage all the positive
efforts all the transitive dialogue in
order to in order to reach peaceful
solutions about the legislation
regarding the citizenship in you know
that in the European Parliament it was
an important topic the last we the last
month and we had the occasion also today
to raise this topic with the Prime
Minister and I would like to say that we
trust the Indian institutions we
understand that the Supreme Court will
have a role to play in order to assess
this legislation and we to the decision
with the Indian authorities to keep to
continue a strong dialogue on the
question of human rights which is very
important for us and for India in order
to exchange good practices and to have
the best possible understanding about
how we tackle these important issues for
India and for the European Union thank
you this concludes our press conference
of today thank you for joining and
please consult our joint declarations on
our websites thanks again